and the war in ukraine is pushing global
food prices sharply higher russia and
ukraine produce nearly a third of the
world's wheat and the conflict is
disrupting supplies russia says it's
willing to allow grain exports from
ukraine but only if the west eases
sanctions against it the united nations
is looking for a solution to avert a
looming food crisis
a friendly visit to vladimir putin
a rare sight as the west announces fresh
sanctions
but senegal's president mackie sal says
it isn't right for africa to be caught
in the crosshairs
cut off from crucial grain imports from
ukraine and russia
current chairperson of the african union
says putin is willing to help
we're leaving here very reassured and
very happy with our exchange it's not
over yet
we must continue discussions with the
other parties so that trade resumes
immediately
there is a catch
russia says it will let green shipments
leave ukraine only if sanctions are
lifted
meanwhile ukraine alleges russia is
stealing grain to supply its allies
the u.n says it's leading tense talks
with russia to release the exports
with a third of global wheat supplies
coming from ukraine and russia the
stakes are enormous
there are 1.4 billion people that can be
affected because of the shortage of
wheat and other grains an unblocking
trade rules in the black sea must remain
the priority failure to open those pores
will result in famine destabilization
and mass migration around the world
with wheat prices already soaring across
africa
a looming global food crisis is fast
becoming a reality for many
and i'm joined now by joe glauber senior
research fellow at the international
food policy research institute he joins
us from washington d.c thank you so much
for taking the time to speak with us
wheat prices have risen by 56 percent
since this time last year around the
world that's translating into people
seeing the cost of the food that they
buy go up but who is suffering the most
from massive increases like that
well as you say these are globally
traded commodities uh the prices are
being felt everywhere in the world but
but clearly the the poorest are feeling
the brunt and and in particular those
those countries that depend heavily on
wheat for consumption so if you look at
countries of the north africa middle
east central asia those are countries
that that consume about twice that of
what we we consume in the u.s or in
europe uh in on a per capita basis so
it's a big part of the diets in egypt
it's 35 of the calories come from wheat
products like bread and uh there you've
seen you know unsubsidized wheat prices
or
bread prices rise astronomically uh
thankfully there are targeted subsidies
in egypt to try to address problems for
the the poorest households but for
countries that have very little
resources to provide towards consumers
and to help
mitigate some of these price impacts
they're the ones that are suffering the
most
now the kremlin denies that it is to
blame for the blockade of ukrainian
ports and the un and the african union
are pushing for them to be reopened how
optimistic should we be that we will see
that happen
i think it's very difficult i would
certainly hope that those ports would be
reopened
it it's difficult
to get those sorts of assurances that uh
i think the world's going to need i mean
remember that these aren't necessarily
countries
to owning the ships these are private
companies they they require
assurances that that their their ships
won't be targeted uh so insurance rates
are extremely high right now and right
now it's just physically uh they're
unable to to move into those ports
because of the mines and because of the
threats even before i mean remember that
russia actually was blockading those
ports a week before the the soldiers
actually came across borders so this has
been a very big problem and it's
expensive to move grain any other way uh
so going out through the west on rail or
barge is just four times the cost of
going down through the black sea okay
i'd like to come back to you in just a
moment but first let's hear from the
world food program uh they've been
warning of global famine if access to
black sea ports is not reopened
so the black sea ports are as it were
the silver bullet when it comes to
avoiding global famines global hunger
but if that silver bullet isn't found we
also need those alliances to support
overland deliveries of food um exporting
from this country a country that fed 400
million people last year
so they're calling those ports a silver
bullet um you touched on this just
briefly but do you think that overland
roots can be a realistic alternative
frankly in the short run i think it's
going to be very difficult i mean it is
you can do it and they are doing it uh
so but it's essentially means shipping
by rail
going upstream if you will because all
the grain typically now comes down
through those ports but you can go back
up through the the out through
into
the
river ports on the danube down to get
ports on in romania or up through poland
and in the baltics to try to get access
to the baltic sea but remember that the
that it adds a lot of cost to do so the
rail gauges aren't the same so that is
the the rail tracks are
are wider in ukraine than they are in in
um romania they have to be offloaded
reloaded
put onto barges then taken down canals
to get to the the blacks to the black
sea and all this adds an enormous amount
of cost plus it just can't handle the
volumes that we typically see going out
of the black sea uh in those ports
around odessa sounds like a huge
logistical challenge
longer term it's not going to be just
about supplies is it but also about
future harvests ukraine spring wheat
crop should be going into the ground
already for harvest this fall for
example how do you see that playing out
in the long term
yeah we we have a bigger problem in the
near term we have the fall planted wheat
uh that is coming uh that right now
people predict around 20 million tons uh
remember that we have about 20 million
tons already stuck in ukraine from last
year that hasn't been marketed which
typically would be marketed before the
new crop comes in and so i think that
that
the the challenge is going to be how to
store that without losing it because it
right now it just can't move in the
volumes that that typically would be
needed
and so um
that means putting it into storage
facilities some of which have been
damaged by the war but the bigger
problem is that they're already
i won't say completely full but they are
already far fuller than they should be
at this time of year so that means
storing grain on the ground or finding
temporary storage all of which adds cost
joe glauber from the international food
policy research institute thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
us thanks claire